[Music]
[Music]
what is up welcome to stick to football
live I don't know what what's happening
in the background right before what live
right we're on vacation so somebody was
apparently getting their stock ready
line up the Coronis baby it is vacation
time after today on stick to football if
you missed the news we're going on
summer break so the Hawaiian shirts come
out I was gonna put my feet on the desk
and smoke a cigar but that hasn't
happened yet Matt no way Connor we still
have a little bit of work to do before
we just turn up for the summer today we
are grading the NFC West drafts
basically I get to cry about my favorite
team after realizing that Melos team and
Connors team probably better than mine
in 2020 I'm ready to go that far with it
that's a bull take don't forget you guys
can leave your draft on draft questions
right here if you're watching in the
Bleacher Report app if you're listening
in the podcast version put this baby on
repeat and let it ride for the next two
months because this is outside of
Twitter all we got for you so it's it's
gonna be a good one we'll go out with a
bang that is for sure the bang you
probably heard with all the cups falling
right before the show started alright
enough of that let's get into the show
we are starting with the San Francisco
49ers today guys
mellow account are gonna give you other
grades and we're gonna run through our
favorite picks and players mellow start
yourself what's your great for this one
buddy for your San Francisco 49ers I
don't understand this draft and what
they're doing here really you get Javon
Kinlaw who I like quite a bit actually
and I really like his fit in this
defense
I think the ceiling for Javon Kinlaw
might be a guy by the name of DeForest
Buckner who's you know hunted from this
spot so do I like to pick yes but I
don't understand the thinking behind
this I don't think the forest Buckner's
even a guy that's ridiculously expensive
he's one of the top at his position I
think he's easily top three interior
defensive lineman in the entire NFL and
now you're going out and you're trying
to replace him I just don't understand
that you're trading back to do it at 14
and again even in the first round I
don't love Brandon Knight yuka I didn't
think that he was the first round talent
I thought there are a lot of other
receivers on the board when he was
drafted and I don't love the other pain
you only had like five pics in this
draft I don't love it I'm gonna give it
a d-minus I really don't see how this
team got that much better this offseason
I liked this draft a little bit more
than you Melo I didn't think it was a
homerun by any standard but I gave it a
B just a flat-out average draft now of
course replacing DeForest Buckner that's
just not very realistic but I think
Javon Kinlaw is gonna be a very good NFL
player at the next level I look at his
body type and his athleticism and that
raw power he can develop into a really
good pass rusher especially playing with
the talent that they already have on
that defensive line Brandon I you cuz
another guy that's a really good scheme
fit there I don't know if I would have
liked him in the first round for many
other teams but when I look at the
Niners NIU he's somebody that can win
down the field but if you scheme him
open he's one of the more dangerous
players in this class with the ball in
his hands so that's exciting to me when
I look at him and Deebo Samuel I know
Matt's favorite quarterback Jimmy G
we'll see if you can get these guys
going but once again this is a really
good addition for their offense and then
I actually think there are some pretty
good value ads in this trap the kibitz
is somebody that I see transitioning to
guard and being decent at it she want
Jennings is the sleeper here for a guy
that went as late as he did he's a
monster after the catch and I don't
think they're gonna use him just as a
wide receiver or a move to type in he'll
play an h-back kind of role so not a by
any means some kind of slam-dunk trap
but I think they got quite a few
productive starters in it yeah guys I
think what I worry about here as someone
who I've been a fan of the steamer since
I was six years old I lived through the
Trent Baalke rain up oh my god we're
drafting these good players like
Marshawn Lattimore
but there's so many or so many injury
concerns you know like that's the thing
Marcus Lattimore sees you're not
Marshawn that's my thing with Kinlaw and
I you you drafted in the first round two
guys who have to play and contribute at
a high level not just right now but for
the next five years his first-round
picks and they both have injury concerns
Javon kianlawl had a hip labrum that had
to be repaired back injuries in two
years both knees have been hurt Brandon
I couldn't run at the Senior Bowl he
couldn't run at the combine he couldn't
do anything pre-draft because of
injuries this reminds me so much of
Trent Baalke where let's just take these
good players who fell to us because the
injury concerns and completely for
getting the fact that they fell to you
because of injury concerns so I don't
like the two first round picks at all
because of that I think there were safer
players on the board and there were
better players on the board when it gets
to the depth they're only 5 picks in
this draft that's another big part of
this cult in the kibbutz I do like I
think is the best value of any pick they
made in the fifth round because I saw
someone that could play tackle in the
NFL could play in that right tackle
position we do have to mention yes they
trade it for Trent Williams that's a big
part of this draft class and we're
hoping that after a year away from
football he's gonna have a seamless
transition back into this offense that
he's never or hasn't played in since
Kyle Shanahan was with the Redskins way
back in the day but Colton the kibitz
whether it's a guard or right tackle I
do think he has good value in this
specific offensive scheme and Connor
mentioned Ron Jennings I like Charlie
Warner pretty well at the tight amount
of Georgia he's gonna be a backup a
backup Titan in the sixth round when you
only have five picks you took a backup
tight in that's the way he moved but
they've hit late on tight ends before so
maybe there's some value there I get a
deal gave it a D my hope in prayer is
that somehow you trade Jimmy Garoppolo
to Houston for deshaun Watson I'm just
starting that rumor right now you know
what is your things have happened I
laugh at it but it's nap exactly right
let's move on to Seattle the team that
is pining for the number one spot in
this drought they have not traded
Russell Wilson yet despite what our good
friend Chris Simms reported was rumored
to have happened back in 2018 Melo how
do they do in this draft with Russ at
quarters I like what they did in this
draft and I think Jordan Brooks was
maybe a little bit of a reach but not as
much as one as people probably think at
the end of the first round I think this
is a linebacker they would have went
early second at the lowest a and he fits
this defense what they want to do
they're getting a little old at the
linebacker position this team doesn't
have a whole lot of needs on it and when
you look at the board and how it felt to
them they probably could have went with
Patrick Queen but I think they like to
fit with Jordan Brooks I mean I know it
came from his agent but he was even
saying this is the best true middle
linebacker in this class he might not
have been wrong I probably would have
had Kenneth Murray ahead of him but when
you look at Patrick Queen there's a lot
of questions with can he come up and
make plays in the backfield like we're
seeing Jordan Brooks do
you don't have those questions so I
really like this pic of Jordan Brooks
I'm gonna give this draft of B+ I really
like what they did here I'm gonna be
honest I just don't know how Seattle
does it they reach in the first round
every single year and they still remain
one of the most competitive teams in the
NFC and I actually think Jordan Brooks
is one of their better reaches in recent
years but once again I felt like you
could have got him probably in the
second round and I thought Patrick Queen
was just a much better linebacker
prospect so getting away though from
Jordan Brooks because I actually was one
of the picks I did like overall because
of I think he'll be a good player
Darrell Taylor was a guy that was
inconsistent in college he came and then
he went he disappeared at times yes
there's some pass-rush upside yet there
yes there's the strength to play at the
run but once again I didn't value him as
a second round player you look at Damian
Lewis and Colby Parkinson I don't know
if Lewis can hold up in pass pearl
Parkinson was a former five-star recruit
you know something that they do value in
previous traps but just wasn't very
productive in college so for Seattle
felt like a lot of reaches do you think
they got a couple decent players but
this is a C for me I just didn't see the
pick that stands out that you go man
that guy's gonna be a franchise player
or a player that we're gonna have for
the next six to eight years and be a
really high-end starter so I'm actually
only complete ops in I gave it an A I
like their draft a lot I drove books at
33 overall and what I do love about it I
know I'm making a big connection here
Bobby Wagner played for Matt wells at
Utah State Jordan Brooks played for Matt
wells at Texas Tech now they're together
with the Seattle Seahawks at linebacker
and I think that's the mentality here
they have built this team around Russell
Wilson and round Bobby Wagner as wagner
starts to get older your hope is the
Jordan Brooks just becomes him just
replaces him in the middle of that
defense drill Taylor had a 79 overall I
liked him as a speed rusher and when we
got out of round one like what's your
door Grossmont us was off the board was
like okay well who's the next best pass
rusher you're basically taking a chance
on traits at that point I thought
Taylor's traits we're off the charts
good so their first two picks I liked
but I want to tell you about a sleeper
that they may have got late in this
draft in round four and that is DJ
Dallas out of Miami you heard us talk
about this with Cam acres at Florida
State
we said all the time the production he
had behind that terrible offensive line
where no quarterback he makes you
believe in him same damn thing for DJ
Dallas just go down in the state you
find a back that I thought was very
similar to cam Akers a little bit
stockier maybe not as much speed but
this is a power runner he is so much
like Chris Carson who is their starting
running back Rashad Penny I'm sorry bro
yeah I know you're a first-round pick I
would not be shocked if DJ Dallas is
taking a big part of that rep cherry in
the background because this is a
talented player with that that body lean
and the power that they want in that
Seahawks are often so I give them an A
in this traffic a Marshawn Lynch type
back Chris Carson tight back don't
forget you guys can sitting in those
draft on draft questions maybe we vote
on who has the best Hawaiian shirt today
Connors got the formal we're going
Melo's ready-to-drink 39 he lights and I
just bought this shirt today so we're
somewhere in between today's show is
sponsored though by PlayStation Home to
NCAA football 2014 the last college
football game incidentally felt they
could put out before ed O'Bannon got mad
and people started asking questions so
dust off Denard Robinson on the cover
and play NCAA 14 where you can play as
illegally unpaid Jameis Winston and lead
the Seminoles to the 2014 national
championship game a matchup Melo
encounter most people will remember as
that legendary duel between current
frigate kickers Cody parky and Roberto
Aguayo
instead of like 14 graphics you're okay
Thank You Playstation for supporting
stick to football I would replace so
much of that game yeah too much do
whatever you want yeah so much I haven't
think about it I'm committed to my golf
game over the summer most Connor what
are you doing with your break that we're
going off the rails here today they
can't stop us what are you doing with
your two months off I thought about golf
honestly I think it's gonna be a lot of
beach time for me the social distancing
version of that some kayaking where you
could literally just paddle away from
anybody that gets near you but I don't
know I'm thinking about it I say I'm
gonna get back into golf every year and
then I absolutely go I'm not doing this
that is me every year as well but we
played last week and I wasn't bad so I
think I'm gonna lean into it cuz we got
time I love the Connors being active
plus you got the shirt
yeah I got the shirt so we got to do all
right let's move on to the Los Angeles
Rams the new uniforms suck
hopefully the draft is better Connor you
get to start with this one I got nothing
for these guys I'm sorry yeah start this
one off the uniforms are trash but the
draft was not at the Rams did a really
good job and this is a team that it felt
like they didn't have any premium
selections but they come out of it with
some premium players cam makers is
somebody that I think is gonna be a
really good starting NFL running back in
all three you know aspects of the game
that it has a pass catcher or pass
protector and inside/outside runner Ben
Jefferson super high floor kind of
player in my eyes that'll fit McVeigh's
scheme very well good route runner good
hands I thought the steal of this group
here guys is actually throughout Burgas
I think he's somebody that's gonna play
the slot at the next level and do a
really really good job of it throat
Louis when he's on the field he's
phenomenal we just don't know if he'll
be able to play guys with the injury
history that he has so when you look at
what the Rams did here this might be a
three player class without any premium
picks that's really really well done I'm
actually curious to see also how they
use Bryson Hopkins in that offense as
well behind Gerald Everett so when you
look at it you get a pretty big piece
for your defense that late in the draft
and a guy like Burgess that let's be
real they need cover players in that
division you have a whole new look on
offense a skill players already the
stack with guys like Cooper Cup and
Robert woods I like the direction the
Rams went in this draft it's a b-plus
all the way for me and I'm right there
with you Connor I'm gonna go a minus for
these guys specifically with the cam
akers thing I didn't know what the
direction of the team was gonna be after
they moved on from Gurley but they got
their running back and I think with a
little bit of offensive line help this
guy can come in and be just as
productive what we saw out of Todd
Gurley at least out over the last two
season we've mentioned it and it feels
like a million times on this show the
guy had no offensive line help and he
was still able to do a damn good job
against some talented ACC defenders I
like cam akers I like that he can come
in immediately and help this offense an
offense that actually needs us quite a
bit of help after last year now Jared
Goff doesn't have to just sit back there
and listen to Sean McVeigh in his ear
all day now we can actually get a
running game
a little bit more help you add a target
later in van Jefferson who I think is
one of the best route runners in this
class a - I thought the Rams did a
really good job with their draft they're
maybe the offseason losers with those
uniforms but a very good draft I just
feel so badly for cam akers you go from
the worst offensive line in college
football to the worst offensive line in
the NFL like my man has no chance at all
hopefully he can get something going no
first rounder doesn't stop this from
being a very good draft some big bets on
injury players so I think that is the
key here will van Jefferson stay healthy
a player I really like Miller said it I
think it was the best route runner in
the entire traffic class Terrell Lewis
first round body fourth round production
at Alabama because you couldn't stay on
the field so that is the key here where
do you get the production from this
class because when you just look at the
names there are five starters here and
you see a man Jefferson if you're
watching the show in the app that route
running is just silky smooth but you
have an older player who has had a foot
injury and never had much production of
Florida I know some of that was on the
quarterbacks before Kyle trash took over
but I think there's a lot of projection
here with this Rams draft so I gave it a
b-minus I think there are a lot of
upside players but this is the biggest
boomer Bluff or bust class excuse me of
the NFC West I would agree with that I
think even those guys like if you don't
get you know cam akers some help we're
gonna say that you wasted a running back
again yeah alright the Arizona Cardinals
I think is the hottest team in the NFC
West maybe in the NFC I know a lot of
fans are mad at me over at counter
please tell everyone why I'm right and
it starts with this draft I love the
direction this team is going in and I'm
with you Matt they're one of the scarier
teams in the NFC quietly they're the
team that you know might finish last and
you're laughing at them and then you go
wait a minute you're two Kyler Murray a
couple pieces like Isaiah Simmons value
like Josh Jones at 72 you beefed up the
interior defensive line as you could see
right there that's gonna help a lot that
was a weakness for them last year this
team should not get run on like they did
last year the steel of it though for me
amongst all of this is getting Ino
Benjamin in the seventh round when I
look at that man he's just a seamless
fit you saw what happened when Kenyan
Drake got traded to Arizona the
production he had now you have a backup
sure he might not be as explosive as
Drake but he could do a lot of the same
things he's a really good pass catcher
he's a tough hard-nosed runner that can
make things happen at the second level
of the field over and over again and a
super high character player that's gonna
go in there and they're just gonna look
to win more football games they have the
quarterback to do it I thought Kliff
Kingsbury gave you a lot of hope in his
debut NFL season I like what the
Cardinals are doing and let's not forget
Chandler Jones he would get more
recognition as a consistent Defensive
Player of the Year candidate if he was
on a better team well guess what they're
gonna be a better team it's a b-plus
here for Arizona yeah I know somebody
was in my Twitter mentions talking about
how much we love Arizona and I said
they're coaches from tech their
quarterbacks from oh you like they could
be in the running for a team I hate the
most but I love what they did in the
draft I'm going to give it a B+ they
obviously get Isaiah Simmons who I love
and I hope they play at multiple
positions but I also love the Josh Jones
pick here I mean this is a guy who I
think we could have seen Arizona trade
back in the first round and pick him up
in the mid first round we would have
said okay that's fine they got this dude
in the third round third round of the
NFL Draft and I think he can come in and
start I almost immediately for them he
might need some time to catch up and
develop a little bit before he's that
left tackle of the future but I think
that he could play some guard a right
tackle get his feet wet in the NFL and
then eventually you have a third-round
pick who could be your left tackle of
the future yeah they did a great job
here I gave it a B and I do think with
Pete he's not me suspended for the first
four games you're gonna have a healthy
defensive line I think this defense is
gonna be nasty this year when you add in
Isaiah Simmons but it's not just him
it's Rashard Lawrence any time you
watched LSU tape this year whether it
was Patrick Queen Jacob Phillips Kayla
van chase on there was a man up front
opening the door and that was Rashard
Lawrence a player I've said on this
podcast before told you guys a million
times in my notes next to his name I
wrote you'll like him don't move him
down no matter what
he was just a beast at that five
technique position I think that's where
he's gonna play in Arizona where you
have Chandler Jones you guys said it he
might be the best pass rusher on
football period he's
good not Rashard Lawrence is gonna keep
offensive tackles off him he's gonna
rock back offensive guards so I really
really like what they're building on
this defensive line I'm giving her to be
I think they got starters in round three
they got starters around four and I've
said about Twitter people got pissed
this is a team that the rest of the NFC
West has to be afraid of
if Kyla Murray can get the ball out a
little bit faster and help his offensive
line they got weapons and now they're
gonna be dangerous on defense when you
look at these teams it's you have to win
your division first in Arizona looked at
it and said we have to beat the San
Francisco 49ers stop the run game you
loaded up with these defensive linemen
you got Isiah Simmons you got somebody
to protect against Nick Bose I like
they're coming for the throats of your
49ers we will give you our picks for the
division after we could see a little bit
more Kliff Kingsbury and our guy Kyler
Murray in some great iron Heights hey
college boy why don't you make like you
did you a Sealy before you get started
good one Joe Thanks bangles coach it's
Zach Taylor Oscar Isaac Daisy Ridley air
the clip tellurium is it true you had a
losing record in college yeah you're
hired
here's a good pass gonna meet you he's
so small okay next bounty we want close
losses to good teams who wants a baby
babies now
[Music]
gridiron tykes might be the only place
you're able to see Josh Rosen
that's how buried he hasn't hit about
right now two years in a row
he gets replaced by a quarterback
drafted in the top 10 so that Josh Rosen
30 for 30 is going to be amazing I can't
wait all right we get to pick some
division winners I think it's Melos turn
to go first but I've honestly lost track
mellow Europe I'm going I didn't even
know we had an order but I'm going with
the Seahawks I really like what they did
in the draft what they're doing in the
offseason and I questioned a lot of the
moves that the 49ers made so I'm going
to bet that we're gonna see a change in
the Seahawks win this thing again I'm
gonna go with the Niners here guys I
look at the addition of Trent Williams I
think he's gonna be ready to go that run
game might look even better they got
more juice at wide receiver right now
George Gibbons George kill that
defensive line will be fine even with
the forest buff they're gone so I look
at the Niners here maybe the most
competitive division in football I'll
say that I'm gonna bet on Kyle Shanahan
yeah I want to badly but I'm gonna take
the Seahawks they've never had a losing
season with Russell Wilson at
quarterback I think they only get better
with some of the additions they made not
just through a very strong draft class
but in free agency also thing that Super
Bowl hangover is gonna be real for the
49ers losing DeForest Buckner I know
it's all about financial health for this
team long term that is a huge not only
the place that he made but the doors
that he opened for Nick for the rest of
that d-line I even
maybe a wild-card team to Seahawks win
this division and I cannot wait to shut
my Twitter down for days you definitely
need to because Bears fans have already
found you now your own team the 49ers do
they cannibalize you yeah we'll see all
right draft on draft time 3 before we
are officially on vacation for two
months the ginger to for this is not me
believe it or not what's the likelihood
that the NFC West repeats with having
boast the NFC Defensive Rookie of the
Year and NFC Offensive Rookie of the
Year with Isiah Simmons being a freak
and cam akers being the lead back in LA
I don't think it's completely out of the
question to get that back-to-back rookie
of the year on defense and offense Isiah
Simmons is gonna be fantastic I think we
all agree about that I wouldn't count
out a guy like Jordan Brooks either
playing weak side linebacker he's gonna
have a big opportunity to make place he
would take Brandon I you basically being
unstoppable offensively I think the
offensive things gonna be tough for
Akers to get going I think he's the
favorite to do it offensively
defensively though you mentioned Jordan
Brooks and even Javon Kinlaw I think he
could come in have some really good
production on that defensive line you
know teams are worried about Nick Bosa
Javon kinloch can come in and get some
sacks from the interior too so I think
there's actually a pretty damn good
chance as long as cam akers or an IU KY
just I don't know if we can get it on
off it's to I don't think it's crazy but
it is a little nuts to pick anyone but
chase young when you look at this here
guys I think he's gonna come in and be a
wrecking ball from day one and listen
Isaiah Simmons is gonna make a big
difference but it might not show up in
the stat sheet that's the problem with
his game it feels like the Defensive
Rookie of the Year it can be a stat
based of ward at times they look at
sacks they look at tackle numbers things
like that so that's one problem and cam
akers actually really liked that pick
because I think when you look at the
offense he's going into now that did
allude to the point that the offensive
line is still a gigantic question mark
but in terms of volume outside of Clyde
Edwards II layer camp makers is in a big
big line right now to get a lot of
volume as a rookie running back yeah I
think one division that has a chance the
NFC East chase young like you mentioned
CD lamb for Dallas
a sneak like oh yeah seedy lamp duh he's
great but him being in Dallas that makes
that an interesting one right Dakota Cox
this question is a toughy
what's a bold sports prediction that you
think would be true by the time stick to
football comes back in July might be fun
to look back at some of these a bold
sports prediction I don't know we're
gonna have sports to make a prediction
about that's the hard thing maybe that's
maybe that'll be my prediction that that
we do have sports by there maybe I'm an
optimist but I think by mid-july we will
have figured this out to where we've
seen some basketball and some baseball
I'll take the high road here with that
one I hope so because if not I don't
know what I'm gonna do with this
vacation bold football take I'll say Cam
Newton is still free agent when we come
back break with nothing no I was gonna
go with the opposite I'll take - I'll
take a fun one I think in a bizarro
world the Cincinnati Reds will be one of
the hottest teams in baseball when you
look at some of the additions they made
and then on the football side however
throw a dart out there I think Cam
Newton is gonna be with the Patriots oh
that is still the betting favorite for
Cam Newton to be a patriot so I got it I
hope baseball comes back I don't even
care if the Orioles are good which is my
nemesis like I want baseball back that
bad I don't care if the Royals win the
World Series they won't but even if they
do I'll be happy for them no it wouldn't
that's the life last draft on draft
question from Pat Chamberlain
sentimental edition what aspect of
hosting stick to football are you gonna
miss the most
dumped during summer hiatus and then on
the other side what are you gonna miss
the least what I'm gonna miss the least
is the amount of time that the set up in
prep takes every day we have an amazing
amazing team that works behind the
scenes that like hour of waiting to go
on is so hard to keep your energy level
up so that when that camera flips live
we're not sitting here like zombies
that's what I'm gonna miss the least
what I'm going to miss the least
sitting in front of these hot damn
lights trying not to sweat so that I
don't have to use you'll sweat rags
right now like a quarterback yeah I
would go with that as well I think
definitely the sweating when you're
doing your show from your apartment or
from home essentially it can be tricky
at times but I know you know everybody
at bleacher report has made the most of
it and we're really fortunate that we
were able to continue with
show definitely the sweating that's
really it I don't really mind anything
else here yeah lights heat up so I do it
clean it's so much I think miss the most
for me is that anytime something newsy
or topical happens I'm wired to text you
guys okay we need to talk about this
tomorrow or we're leading the show with
this I think that's what I'll miss the
most like the camaraderie of building
the show plans of executing them
everything that goes on behind the
scenes of this is a branch that we're
basically running damn near full-time so
we'll have to find something random to
keep our group text going about but
that's what I'll miss the most
hopefully it's baseball hopefully it is
baseball there will be some side bets
for sure I think filling the void is
definitely one I think it's a great
point Matt whenever there's news in the
world for the last three years it really
hasn't been one of those things where we
sit there and digest that we rather we
go how are we gonna talk about this on
the show with our audience so I think
that's the thing now we're entering
probably a month or two here where it's
not gonna be a lot of football news so
if there was ever a time for us to take
a little break come back bigger and
better this would be it but that's
definitely the element for me yeah well
set that is our show thank you so much -
Sean McManus our producer who has worked
his tail off since stick to football has
gone live we appreciate it
we'll be back two months the music's
gonna play us out I need a ukulele
follow us on Twitter we will still be
there a stick to football at Malone at
Connor Jay Rogers and NFL Draft Scout
until July you guys have a good summer
we'll be back
[Music]
[Music]